à tunis notre envoyé spécial bassam
shelly bonjour bassem la situation
sanitaire est toujours préoccupante en
tunisie alors que le confinement vient
d'être levée à quelles sont les
nouvelles mesures qui ont été prises par
le gouvernement
bonjour ma galerie bonjour olivier
effectivement tunisie la situation
sanitaire est toujours délicate
gouvernement a du mal à pallier à cette
reconnaissance de 4 pour un virus avec
des hôpitaux saturés 100% des liants
d'animation qui sont occupées ma clé et
quelques hôpitaux de fortune qui ont été
installés sur l'ensemble du pays ça ne
suffit toujours pas pour accueillir tous
ces patients malades d'hugo vide donc
après ce couvre feu reste de confinement
généraliser le goût re est toujours de
rigueur ici entre 20h et 5h du matin les
restaurants les bars les gaz auront pu
rouvrir hier mais peuvent accueillir 30
% de leur capacité ce qui est fait
rassemblement tout est interdit à ce
niveau là et il faut savoir qu'on a
atteint plus de simplement de 200 mille
cas confirmés avec 6880 sept décès
depuis le début de cette crise la
réouverture des écoles
elle a été les écoles ont rouvert par an
à partir du 24 mai beaucoup de parents
sont réticents à l'idée de renvoyer
leurs enfants à l'école c'est le même
cas aussi pour tout ce qui est étudiant
et d'universitaires qui ont décidé de ne
pas retourner à la fac y ont même décidé
de rejoindre les différents mouvements
de manifestations qui ont éclaté depuis
le 14 janvier dernier jour du premier
film en généralisée qui symbolisait
aussi anniversaire des dix ans de la
révolution alors bassem une crise
sanitaire qui vient s'ajouter à une
crise économique et sociale
le climat est toujours aussi tendue
alors que le chef de l'état s'est
adressé à la nation hier c'était 24
heures avant le vote de confiance à
l'assemblée nationale effectivement
livré à plat la situation politique
économique est toujours aussi tendue ici
depuis le 14 janvier temps comme je vous
ai dit quand et des tensions ont éclaté
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
qui ne comprenait pas pourquoi avoir mis
en place le premier jour
en filmant généraliser le 14 janvier
date les dix ans de la révolution
c'est une date deux continents
généralisée qui a mis de l'huile sur le
feu en tunisie dans une situation
économique déjà très sensible est
catastrophique et dix ans après la
révolution ils se sont confiés à djibo
demande visant à prague avoir acquis
plus de liberté d'un point de vue
d'expression
rien n'a changé voire la situation
nettement empirer on a une plus assister
dans différents quartiers de la capitale
et aussi dans l'ensemble du territoire
deux extensions tous les choix entre des
jeunes et puis entre elles la police ya
eu beaucoup d'arrestations pour couteau
comparution devant la justice le
président leur et public ainsi que les
premiers ministres s'étaient même
adressé à la nation pour calmer les
tensions mais rien n'y fait le présent
est ressorti hier devant nation pour
s'adresser au peuple juste 24 heures
avant ce vote de confiance qui doit
avoir lieu à l'assemblée nationale à
partir de ce soir le premier ministre a
constitué un nouveau gouvernement et le
chef de l'état à d'ores et déjà confirmé
qu'ils n'étaient pas d'accord avec le
choix du premier ministre certains
ministres qui ont été choisis ne
correspondent pas à l'idée que je
faisais le président de la tunisie il a
jugé certains corrompus il a même dit
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de femmes dans
cette nouvelle nomination ce qu'on peut
savoir ces manifestations sont toujours
existence la situation est toujours
tendue aujourd'hui une grosse
manifestation je prépare le gouvernement
a peur de cette manifestation c'est une
première on a de plus observé car il ya
eu des barbelés et des blindés qui ont
été installés tout autour de l'assemblée
nationale c'est le cortège qui est prévu
par ces jeunes qui veulent aller jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale et car pour
réussir dans le coeur du problème et
notamment le parti ennahda le parti
islamiste au pouvoir qu'ils rendent
responsables tous les maux la société
surtout de la situation économique que
lille actuellement la tunisie
voilà ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
tensions sont toujours aussi palpable
aujourd'hui une grande manifestation se
prépare à tous merci beaucoup bassène
pour toutes ces précisions voici on va
suivre cela bien sûr dans les prochaines
heures avec vous